immer mehr masken in deutschland der
atemschutz wird pflicht in vielen
bundesländern aber nicht alle machen mit
aus für das oktoberfest münchen sagt
devisen ab für die fans und die lokale
wirtschaft ein schwerer schlag und titel
am grünen tisch die handball-bundesliga
errechnet kiel als deutschen meister und
bricht die saison ab
nachrichten sich das heute mit christian
sievers die welt an diesem dienstag
guten abend hinein
die masken kommen für uns alle wohl in
den geschäften in bussen und bahnen im
kampf gegen das virus hatte die
bundesregierung zuletzt masken dringend
empfohlen
jetzt wird das tragen von masken pflicht
in fast allen bundesländern eine
einheitliche linie allerdings gibt es
nicht
den anfang hatte sachsen gemacht da gilt
schon seit gestern eine masken pflicht
für geschäfte und den nahverkehr in
sachsen anhalt ab übermorgen und den
thüringen ab freitag am montag folgen
bayern baden württemberg hamburg und
wohl hessen außerdem mecklenburg
vorpommern und berlin da ist der
atemschutz aber nur in bussen und bahnen
vorgeschrieben mittwoch nächster woche
folgt schleswig-holstein anselm stern
berichtet unsichtbar ist das virus immer
sichtbarer werden die mittel dagegen wie
hier in münchen viele menschen mit
masken in immer mehr städten in immer
mehr bundesländern wird der mund und
nasenschutz zur pflicht beim einkaufen
und auch in bus und bahn
komisch ist schon wenn jeder mit maske
rumläuft aber ich denke halt aufgrund
der aktuellen lage von krone muss man
schon was tun
zum ersten mal ist noch etwas ungewohnt
aber ich denke man gewöhnt sich an alles
mit maske zum shoppen das empfehlen
mittlerweile auch offiziell die
virologen vom robert-koch-institut
verbinden die empfehlung aber mit einer
warnung die mund nase bedeckung ersetzt
nicht andere empfehlung es muss weiter
abstand gehalten werden
die mund nasen bedeckung ist ein
zusätzlicher baustein und sie ist allein
kein sicherer schutz vor allen dingen
nicht für sich selbst
wie hoch also ist der schutzfaktor fest
steht so experten die masken erschweren
dem virus den weg von einem menschen zum
anderen wenn sie in öffentlichen
verkehrsmitteln sind dann ist es
natürlich schwierig den abstand wirklich
einzuhalten wenn es hier voll wird
morgens in der u bahn in münchen kann
kein mensch ein meter fünfzig abstand
einhalten und gerade in solchen
situationen macht der bund nasenschutz
einfach absolut sinnvoller schutz den zu
beschaffen kein ganz einfaches
unterfangen sind doch medizinische und
selbst genähte masken mangelware
die medizinischen sollte man wirklich
den medizinischen einrichtungen auch
belassen
aber man kann die dinge wirklich sehr
gut selber nähen und es gibt viele leute
die nicht nur für sich sondern auch
vielleicht für drei vier andere etwas
nähen können
die anti corona masken sie könnten im
schlimmsten fall aber auch zum risiko
werden sagt die bundesärztekammer
sie fassen sich unter umständen viel
häufiger ins gesicht als sie es
eigentlich sollten
und insofern sind die negativen effekte
die tendenziell und theoretisch das
masken tragen auch ausgelöst werden
können unter umständen mindestens ebenso
schlecht wie die positive oder andere
noch einen positiven und in der summe
würde ich sagen muss es eine freiwillige
entscheidung werden freiwillig oder
pflicht immer mehr menschen in
deutschland tragen die maske im kampf
gegen das virus
ja wenn wir jetzt auch mal ein bisschen
zurück gucken was da zum thema masken
aus der politik für empfehlungen kamen
dann ist das schon einigermaßen
verwirrend einiges hin und her erst sehr
skeptisch was masken angeht und jetzt
sind wir bei der masken pflicht wie
gerade gesehen theo guten abend was
steckt denn hinter dieser
informationspolitik und ich glaube in
gewisser weise sind die masken ein
spiegelbild den umgang mit dieser krise
die politik ist bei der korona
bewältigung ja stark abhängig von den
bewertungen und einschätzungen der
wissenschaft die die aber steckt
offensichtlich selbst in einem
lernprozess wenn führende
wissenschaftler anfangs verkünden die
meisten masken sind wirkungslos um dann
wochen später dazu zu raten dass wir
alle masken tragen sollen
dann geht natürlich vertrauenskapital
verloren wobei im fall der masken auch
die anfängliche begründung dass man mit
den masken nur die anderen schützen und
nicht sich selbst fand ich immer wenig
überzeugen denn wenn alle masken tragen
müssten dann werden eben auch alle
geschützt sind
der zweite wichtige punkt den die masken
er exemplarisch klar gemacht haben die
politik war einfach nicht vorbereitet
wir hatten große pandemie studien und
dennoch gab es nicht genug
schutzkleidung auch da sind die masken
eine art spiegelbild interessante
hintergründe und dann müssen wir
vielleicht ein bisschen langfristiger
gucken theo heute ist auch ein tag an
dem die politik durchaus auf die
langstrecke guckt und die menschen so
ein bisschen darauf vorbereitet dass der
sommer und der herbst ohne chor ohne
einschränkungen dann wohl ein frommer
wunsch bleiben werden
ja und vielleicht sogar noch für weitere
jahreszeiten danach die ansage dass wir
erst am anfang einer pandemie stehen die
kam er schon ziemlich früh auch aus der
politik aber durch die gesetzten daten
hat sich dann glaube ich der blick sehr
verkürzt erst waren es 14 tage kontakt
beschränkungen dann bis zum 20 april
jetzt wird am 8 mai neu bewerte ich
glaube allerdings auch dass wir uns alle
selbst an die nase unsere eigenen
erwartungen fassen müssen
der bundesaußenminister jedenfalls hat
heute nach einem gespräch mit seinen
ausländischen kollegen verkündet einen
normalen sommer urlaub ohne
einschränkung den
werde es nicht geben und volle strandbar
soderbergh hat er gesagt schon gar nicht
karl lauterbach hat es noch überboten
heute gesagt einen impfschutz könnte es
vielleicht sogar erst in 2022 geben also
die botschaft der politik hier wird
immer klarer leben mit dem virus ist die
neue normalität und wird es lange
bleiben
theo koll zdf berlin herzlichen dank sie
bleiben auch beim thema keine konzerte
kein kino keine vollen fußballstadien
die absagen gehen weiter jetzt bis
mindestens herbst in berlin etwa alle
großveranstaltungen bis ende oktober
abgesagt und aus münchen kommt heute
eine traurige nachricht für alle freunde
diesen satz wird es dieses jahr nicht
geben
so ist das traditionell wenn die wiesn
eröffnet wird seit heute ist klar kein
oktoberfest 2020 den verantwortlichen
ist die ansteckungsgefahr zu groß jürgen
bollmann hat mehr
der festplatz im zeichen der pandemie
eine corona teststation auf der münchner
theresienwiese die frühzeitige absage
für das oktoberfest ein deutliches
signal dass eine grundlegende besserung
der infektionswelle bis zum herbst nicht
erwartet wird ganz viel dafür spricht
dass nicht noch ein zwei monate
hinauszuzögern zum einen glaube ich
macht wenig hoffnung zu machen wenn man
sich sicher ist dass so was nicht
stattfinden kann
oktoberfest 2009 10 um die sechs
millionen besucher aus aller welt
kontakt vermeiden unmöglich die absage
jetzt ein finanzieller schock einnahmen
von rund 1,2 milliarden euro
nun verloren vor allem die schausteller
trifft es hart
2020 ein jahr ohne nennenswerte umsätze
verzweiflung über dem oktoberfest haben
wir jetzt
noch die krone auf sämtliche absagen
dieses jahres bekommen und das gleicht
einer naturkatastrophe
das ist wie eine dürre oder
geschäftlicher totalausfall
hotels restaurants jetzt schon in
kurzarbeit und nun die große hoffnung
auf das große geschäft im herbst
geplatzt
auch alle anderen gross feste müssen
sich auf absagen einstellen solange es
keinen ausreichenden medizinischen
schutz gibt so bayerns ministerpräsident
mit krone zu leben heißt vorsichtig zu
leben solange es keinen impfstoff gibt
solange es kein medikament nimmt gibt
muss besonders bei aufgepasst wird und
es geht nicht nur um den finanziellen
schaden beklagen auch die betroffenen
es sei ebenso ein großer verlust für die
bayerische kultur und lebensart wie das
virus in alltag verändert das ist auch
thema in einem zdf spezial direkt nach
uns und in der zdf- heute- app da
beschreiben fachleute und politiker wie
der sommerurlaub in diesem jahr aussehen
könnte wie entwickelt sich die pandemie
bei uns in deutschland ganz aktuell eine
wichtige kennzahl dafür ist die
sogenannte re produktionszahl die ist
laut robert-koch-institut wieder leicht
gestiegen
das heißt ein infizierter steckt im
schnitt 0,9 menschen an
damit wird das gesundheitssystem in
absehbarer zeit aber nicht überlastet
die zahl der als neu infiziert
gemeldeten tendiert dagegen weiter nach
unten anfang des monats waren es noch
fast 7000 infektionen an einem tag
gestern wurden dagegen in deutschland
etwa 1900 neue infektionen erfasst
insgesamt gibt es laut johns hopkins
universität stand vor einer halben
stunde 147 1593 durch tests bestätigte
infektionen in deutschland 95 1200 der
betroffenen gelten als genesen 4869
menschen sind in verbindung mit dem
corona virus gestorben
eine welt die nahezu still steht braucht
auch kaum noch etwas von dem was sie
sonst antreibt öl weniger nachfrage
sorgt für einen niedrigeren preis und
jetzt zu einem phänomen bei dem man
zweimal hingucken muss denn das gab es
noch nie der preis für us rohöl
er wurde zwischenzeitlich negativ dass
heißt theoretisch bekäme man noch geld
dafür wenn man öl kauft grund
warentermingeschäfte und die sorge dass
billige öl teuer lagern zu müssen
auch die verbraucher spüren dass der
benzinpreis feld von 1 eur 43 am ersten
januar auf jetzt 1 eur 16
und auch für heizöl ist die gelegenheit
günstig aus hamburg sven rieten die
arbeitstage von maik dieckmann sind im
moment zehn bis zwölf stunden lang der
heizöl fahrer ist im großraum hamburg
unterwegs von früh bis spät alle kunden
die nur ein wenig platz im tank haben
bestellen derzeit ist also der tank leer
ist und wie man sieht wie sehr erfreut
dass ich jetzt endlich mal da bin chef
stefan mross seit mehr als 30 jahren im
geschäft einen solchen andrang hat er
bislang noch nicht erlebt kein wunder
seit januar fiel der preis für heizöl
von mehr als 70 euro pro 100 liter auf
unter 50 im januar noch warten konnte
und den tank heute vollmacht spart bei
einer normalen zweieinhalb tausend liter
lieferung rund 750 euro wir helfen uns
augen mit aushilfsfahrer hinzu
gemieteten oder geliehenen fahrer die
einfach dieses auftragsvolumen
sukzessive abarbeiten
aber anders kann man es gar nicht machen
so stark wie der heizölpreis sind die
kosten für benzin nicht vom öl abhängig
dafür sind zu viele abgaben auf dem
liter trotzdem sank heute nachmittag
lieber dieser freien tankstelle in
hamburg der dieselpreis auf unter einen
euro
deswegen will abgefahren zum tanken
also ich war viel weil ich nämlich
heftig braucht also von daher von mir
aus kann immer so bleiben
momentan spricht auch für experten
vieles dafür dass der ölpreis niedrig
bleibt weltweit betrachtet müssen wir
davon ausgehen dass in diesem jahr und
wahrscheinlich noch weit ins jahr 2021
die ölpreise corona bedingt sehr niedrig
bleiben werden für maik dieckmann und
seine kollegen heißt das in jedem fall
auch für die kommenden wochen heizöl
liefern zehn bis zwölf stunden am tag
dann müssen wir noch mal nachfragen bei
frank bethmann in frankfurt fand wie
kommt sowas zustande öl das auf einmal
gar nichts mehr kostet dabei kommen
wirklich zwei dinge zusammen die großen
öl produzenten wissen nicht wohin mit
ihrem rohöl die haben im wahrsten sinne
des wortes den druck dass wenn keiner
mehr rohöl kauft ihre förderanlagen
stillstehen da gibt man dann kurzfristig
lieber mal geld dazu absatzförderung
nennt man das wohl
denn die riesigen tanklager der abnehmer
die raffinerien die sind ja bereits
jetzt randvoll mit öl sogar die öltanker
dienen inzwischen als schwimmende lager
also wohin mit dem ganzen öl und diese
frage sorgte dann gestern und heute fast
für panik auch am terminmarkt dort also
wo die ölpreise für die kommenden monate
bestimmt werden
am terminmarkt handelt man nicht mit
physischen öl sondern mit verträgen und
wer so einen termin kontakt hatte und
nicht wollte dass im mai tankzüge dann
mit rohöl vor der tür stehen der musste
bis heute zum stichtag sehen dass er die
los wird also kauf mir bitte das papier
ab ich zahl auch was dafür dass im
kurzen die geschichte
was für eine zeit frank vielen dank
unterschiedliche situationen
unterschiedliche antworten das ist das
große plus wenn ein staat föderal
organisiert ist und vieles vor ort
entschieden wird
aber welchen sinn macht es das in
deutschland auch die korona hilfen je
nach bundesland unterschiedlich
ausfallen
und zwar nicht nur wenn es darum geht
wie schnell die zahlungen kommen sondern
auch wie hoch sie sind isabel de la vega
über ein innerdeutsches finanz gefälle
thomas reitz hat ein kleines unternehmen
für veranstaltungstechnik weil wegen
corona fast alle aufträge weggebrochen
sind beantragte er einen zuschuss aus
dem soforthilfeprogramm des bundes in
rheinland pfalz muss das bei der
landesförderbank isb gemacht werden
reitz hat aber auch noch ein weiteres
unternehmen in berlin und auch für
dieses unternehmen beantragt er bei der
zuständigen berliner förderbank den
einmaligen zuschuss 9000 euro ergebnis
in berlin ist das sehr unkompliziert das
ist sehr zügig bearbeitet worden ich
habe nach drei tagen das geld auf einem
konto gab in rheinland pfalz habe ich
den antrag
ich denke es jetzt drei wochen her vor
drei wochen gestellt und ich habe
seitdem von der esb nichts mehr gehört
bei der isb in mainz kommt die
bearbeitung der anträge nur schleppend
in gang erklärt wird das so wir haben
auch dafür gesorgt dass das geld nicht
auf den konten von betrügern landet
sondern bei denen die wirklich der hilfe
bedürften die betrugsfälle die man aus
anderen bundesländern hört stimmen ein
nachdenklich mittlerweile hat die spd
die zahl der mitarbeiter für die
bearbeitung der anträge von 60 auf 130
aufgestockt im benachbarten hessen
kümmern sich über 700 mitarbeiter darum
und es gibt auch höhere zuschüsse als im
nachbarland weil hessen die bundeshilfen
aufstockt in rheinland-pfalz bekommen
nur unternehmen mit bis zu zehn
mitarbeitern einen einmaligen zuschuss
maximal 15.000 euro größere müssen einen
kredit beantragen
in hessen gibt es auch für größere
firmen cash 30.000 euro für firmen mit
bis zu 50 mitarbeitern und in bayern
sogar 50.000 euro bei bis zu 250
mitarbeitern
ein förder flickenteppich und das
bedeutet das für einen kleinen
unternehmen mit 520 mitarbeiter das
risiko der insolvenz in dem einen
bundesland größer ist als in den anderen
unternehmer bereits wünschen sich dass
die zukunft ihres unternehmens nicht
davon abhängt in welchem bundesland sie
sind 75 jahre nach ende des zweiten
weltkriegs gedenkt israel heute der
opfer des holocaust und das mitten in
der korona krise
da kommt ein ganzes land zum stillstand
das ist immer so an diesem tag dieses
mal aber steht das land bereits still
nicola albrecht wir erinnern uns von
name und umarmen aus der ferne steht auf
ihren plakaten
zwei minuten lang schrillen die sirenen
zwei minuten in denen ganz israel
normalerweise zum stillstand kommt und
gemeinsam der opfer des holocaust
denkt doch das land steht bereits still
es herrscht ausgangssperre
wer einen hat lässt den privaten balkon
zum öffentlichen ort des gedenkens
werden
[Musik]
meine mutter hat das kz auschwitz
birkenau überlebt ist es schwer weil wir
nicht mit dem zusammen gedenken können
die besonders in unserem herzen silla
die zentrale zeremonie der gedenkstätte
yad vashem wurde für fernsehen und
internet aufgezeichnet ohne gäste und
ohne überlebende kurze videofilme
persönliche erzählungen skizzieren ihre
schicksale wie das von so hart wir
treffen den 92-jährigen zu hause in
seinem garten er ist traurig dass er
nicht live und vor ort zu den menschen
sprechen konnte
dass alle öffentlichen zeremonien
abgesagt wurden
erinnerst du dich die ganze zeit daran
aber die gesellschaft erinnert sich weil
es den gedenktag gibt und ich finde das
so wichtig veteran der israelischen
armee bringen überlebenden blumen nach
hause
sie gehören zur risikogruppe die
isolation eine dringende empfehlung
ich würde dich gerne umarmen ruft die
87-jährige diener ben simon dem kurier
zu immerhin es tröstet ein wenig zu
wissen dass man auch jetzt nicht
vergessen werde
wir leben in zeiten in denen die
freiheit der presse
ganz besonders in gefahr gerät weil die
mächtigen in manchen ländern den kampf
gegen das virus missbrauchen um ihnen
ungelegen de berichte zu verhindern
davor warnt die organisation reporter
ohne grenzen sie hat heute ihre
jährliche rangliste veröffentlicht
besonders gut stehen darauf die
skandinavischen länder da norwegen
finnland und dänemark deutschland hat
sich leicht verbessert und liegt auf
platz elf ziemlich weit hinten china nur
wenige plätze vor dem schlusslicht
nordkorea
welche bedeutung die pressefreiheit
gerade in corona zeiten hat zeigt sich
in serbien das im jahresvergleich etwas
abgerutscht ist wolf christian ullrich
berichtet die serbische journalistin
anna latsch landete unlängst im
gefängnis weil sie etwas geschrieben
hatte dass ihre regierung
nicht passt es ging um die korona krise
und darum dass in diesem krankenhaus
schutzausrüstung fürs personal fehlte
ich hatte es gewagt zu sagen dass es ein
problem gibt und dass man das problem
nicht verschweigen darf ich begriff
leute das hier ist eine diktatur
ich fürchtete wenn sie uns so offen
mundtot machen können wo hört das auf in
serbien gelten aktuell strengen
notstands dekrete wegen corona doch die
lage von journalisten war schon vorher
besorgniserregend bei einem ortstermin
treffen wir serbiens präsidenten der im
land praktisch durch regiert das
parlament ist bis jetzt ausgesetzt
diejenigen die sich am meisten über
mangelnde pressefreiheit beschweren sind
die die die meiste freiheit haben jeder
hat hier das recht zu sagen was er denkt
vujic weit hier eine zug linie 1 mit
hilfe russlands und chinas gebaut
ausgerechnet von seinen chinesischen
freunden schaue er sich zu viel ab klagt
der unabhängige serbische
journalisten-verband mein eindruck ist
dass die regierung den chinesischen
umgang mit journalisten auch hier
etablieren möchte im ranking von
reporter ohne grenzen steht serbien
nunmehr auf platz 93 kroner ist der
leider nur ein vorwand in vielen ländern
um eigentlich autoritäre reflexe
auszuleben das was dort passiert ist
nicht mit den grundwerten der eu und den
grundrechten vereinbar anna latsch
wartet jetzt auf ihren prozess
einschüchtern lassen will sie sich auch
in zukunft nicht so und jetzt können wir
noch einen meister gratulieren dem
allerdings nicht wirklich zum feiern
zumute ist der neue deutsche handball
meister bei den männern heißt thw kiel
der titel wurde errechnet denn die
handball-bundesliga hat heute wegen
corona die reißleine gezogen und die
saison abgebrochen anja fröhlich
ein deutscher meister ohne meisterfeier
dennoch die kieler sind stolz auf den 21
titel in der vereinsgeschichte den sie
natürlich am liebsten gemeinsam feiern
würden
ja es irgendwie immer noch ein komisches
gefühl klar ist man irgendwie stolz dass
man deutscher meister geworden ist aber
ja wie ist der handball momentan so weit
weg und irgendwie denkt man gar nicht
drüber nach und natürlich werden jetzt
glaube ich auch lieber irgendwie auf dem
rathausplatz oder in der halle die 36
handball clubs der ersten und zweiten
liga sprechen zwar von einer ungerechten
lösung halten dennoch die heute
getroffene entscheidung für die beste
denn das meiste geld verdienen die
bundesligisten durch sponsoren und mit
eintrittskarten geisterspiele medien
spiele sind schwer zu organisieren für
mannschaften nach dem fußball weil es
wirtschaftlich überhaupt nicht abbildbar
ist bei den frauen ebenfalls ein
vorzeitiger abbruch aber dort gibt es
keinen deutschen meister da noch fast
ein drittel der saison zu spielen sei so
die offizielle begründung welche
unfassbare leistung ärztinnen und ärzte
schwestern pfleger gerade vollbringen
und wie sie das auch nach einer schicht
zusammen schweißt das können wir uns
vielleicht ein klein bisschen vorstellen
wenn wir uns jetzt mal diese bilder
ansehen
das ist corona choreografie wenn man so
will auf einer krankenstation in genua
italien 45 tage hintereinander weg ist
dieses team im einsatz getrennt von den
eigenen familien und jetzt step by step
gegen den stress mit zwei wichtigen
botschaften an uns alle feiern wir das
leben und wie es im song heißt bleibt zu
hause viel sonne wärme und viel wind das
ist das wetter gleich mit katja hornuf
an
ich empfehle ihnen den kollegen claus
kleber im heute journal um 21.45 und
kann ihnen versichern wir sind auch
morgen wieder da
um punkt 7 für diesen dienstag und von
der gesamten crew danke für ihr großes
interesse und wo immer das geht in allen
ein angenehmer
[Musik]